go red
the countertops of all the liquor stores
and then go to Nabisco or one of the big
boys and be like hey guess what I want
10 000 countertops you want to put your
widget there you want to put your
[__] widget there
keep the money yeah keep the money
foreign
[Music]
okay everyone what's going on this is
Sam we have Jesse itzler on the Pod
today very fascinating guy started a
bunch of different companies
um the biggest one being Marquee Jets
which we got into some of the economics
of that business and then he's done a
bunch of other things you see him on
social media he's done a lot of stuff
but like his life advice was actually
really amazing
um we went deep into some of the numbers
behind some of his businesses we um
learned about his early career and
there's like a a ton of takeaways the
Pod was only supposed to be 60 Minutes
long but Sean and I were like so into it
that we went over I think we went like
90 minutes something like that because
his story is super fascinating if you
like the Rob Dyrdek episode which a lot
of people did it's I think our most
listened to episode of all time I think
you're really gonna like this one
um it was pretty spectacular I left
feeling good uh about it and if you're
watching this on YouTube do me a favor
hit that subscribe button and make a
comment because we've had a ton of
people comment on our videos lately and
a ton of people subscribe we see the
data behind it so it's awesome that you
guys are doing this and it means a ton
of us we actually text each other all
the time when someone makes a funny
comment so let us know and if you're
listening on iTunes or Spotify hit that
download or the Subscribe button
whatever it is on those platforms
because we get notifications about those
too and it's awesome we're killing it
we're growing a ton and we appreciate
the army of people who are supporting us
all right enjoy the episode let us know
in the YouTube comments what you think
um all right well welcome we got Jessie
itzler here
um also known as I think you might be
the richest Runner white rapper in the
country so congratulations my friend
we we are excited to have you here I
love that if you keep adding categories
I could be the richest in the world if
you start adding like you know
then have four kids that eat plant-based
etc etc so right on so you know I'm
excited to talk to you because you've
done a bunch of amazing things we've
talked about you on the Pod and we sort
of spoke it into existence I think we
talked about it somebody might have sent
you a clip I'm not sure
but you uh you reached out and said hey
I'd love to come on you have I'm just
going to read a couple of these things
so I'm gonna flatter you real quick just
so that the audience uh understands kind
of just your background
so like we said started out uh trying to
make it as a rapper and ended up
creating a a Jingles company so you were
making Jingles for for sports teams
ended up selling that and created uh
Marquee Jets a fractional jet owning
company sold that to Berkshire Hathaway
which Warren Buffett obviously runs and
owns uh you're married to Sarah Blakely
founder of Spanx you are an epic sort of
Fitness athlete yourself so uh prolific
Runner I read your book uh the day I got
really into you was when I read living
with a seal which is the story of you
living with uh David Goggins for 30 days
um I can't even really listen like David
Goggins for 30 minutes on a podcast uh
so living with it for 30 days respect
and um yeah you've created a bunch of
companies outside that partner with zico
coconut water and doing a bunch of
prolific things so you have a a very
prolific career but the start was uh
like anybody it was humble humble
beginnings so talk about the early days
when you were you were trying to do the
let's start with the jingle company you
um you told me you were you were
sleeping on couches at the time trying
to make it and uh describe kind of what
was going on at that time in your life
what was the plan and what were you
going through how did you come out of
that
well I grew up in New York in the 80s
when rap and hip-hop was starting to
emerge in a bigger way and that it that
was the intersection of of that
happening and me going to college so I
was really into music early on and while
all my friends and college were writing
resumes and going on job interviews I
was like I'm making a rap record like
I'm why would I waste my time making a
resume I want to make an album so it was
like kind of that's the direction I
wanted to go in uh right away I ended up
signing with the record company called
delicious vinyl everybody passed on me
and this one little record company
gave me a shot and I didn't have met
like I wasn't super connected I didn't
have like a lawyer I know I just did it
all I shopped it myself but I ended up
getting dropped from the label shortly
after and I got into writing um Jingles
or uh for companies and theme songs for
sports teams and that was kind of my
first entree into you know I pivoted it
didn't work out for me in the music
business but I still loved music so I
stayed in there and I started doing
jingles and um
yeah that's how I kind of started out
early on you told me you were sleeping
on couches
um trying to make it and somebody
offered you a tempting deal they said
yeah I'll give you ten thousand dollars
if I can get ten percent
of everything you'll ever make
how did that happen and what was your
answer
right so I was I was writing theme songs
for sports teams I was 22 23 years old
and my business model was to write a
song on spec and then cold call a
professional sports team try to get a
meeting with them try to like you know
get in there and then if I was able to
get that meeting convince them that they
needed a theme song and that was my
business model and at the time I was I
was I was bouncing around from couch to
couch I wasn't homeless but my friends
were I just moved to New York from Los
Angeles and my friends were putting me
up as I tried to figure out how to do it
I had no money to go in the studio to
write any more songs on spec so I needed
money to fund that production so a music
manager said you know I I believe in you
I'll give you 10 grand for 10 but I want
to own you for the rest of your life
basically 10 of anything you make and I
was like I'll take it because I needed
the money to go with this dude I thought
it was a deal in the set tree you're
gonna give me 10 grand
and all I'm going to do is pay you if I
make it like that sounded amazing to me
at the time I was living on my friend
Melissa Katz uh couch I met her actually
at a bar and she had given me her number
on a napkin and said if you're in an
emergency she asked me where I lived and
I said as of Monday I had nowhere to
live I was getting kicked out of my
friend's house on Monday she said it's
an emergency you can come live with my
roommate and I Monday my friend kicked
me out because his parents were coming
for a week and I'm like this is an
emergency so I'll just leave to get
Melissa's house and I told her about
this opportunity and she said well why
don't you go talk to my father before
you give away 10 of your future earnings
and as it turned out her father was a
very successful entrepreneur he owned
the company called Kenny Park any
parking garages in New York and was uh I
think the second largest shareholder of
the New York Yankees you're like Melissa
your apartment is really nice
[Laughter]
what was amazing about that was it
really wasn't and that's why I really
was taken aback by I knew her dad was an
entrepreneur I didn't know the extent
and
um should you know she said Me On by the
way his name is Lou Katz he passed away
a couple of years ago he was an
incredibly influential guy in my life
and this was my first encounter with
them so I went to not the believer this
but I went to see him and it's really
relevant for anyone listening what he
said to me as a 22 year old he I told
him my dilemma I'm going to take 10
grand for 10 of my life and he said to
me is exactly what he said to me he said
Jesse you know will you make this
business work without the 10 grand I
said Lou I'm on to something I know I
can make it work there's a I know I can
and he he took his notebook and he
literally threw it on the ground and he
said I didn't ask you that
I didn't ask you can you I said will you
there's a big difference between Cad and
will
I know you can start a podcast I know
you can be a millionaire I know you can
run a marathon I I said will you son and
I said yeah well Lou I will he said well
tell him to take the ten thousand
dollars and shove it up his ass don't
make it work and I did you know like it
was a really powerful lesson and like
you know what I signed up for this
journey as an entrepreneur let me go
figure it out let me go that's what I
want to do let me go figure this out and
he keep breathe he blew that flame into
me at an early age and um it's really
been a theme throughout my life in all
the buckets of my life the whole will
verse can notion you know and why why is
that so powerful the will verse can
well because it's it really puts the
pressure you know Billie Jean King in a
book pressure's a privilege
and it is like entrepreneur we play for
pressure showing like as entrepreneurs
that's what we want man and
um you know I recently did a race called
Ultraman it's a 6.2 mile Open Water Swim
a 265 mile bike and a 52.4 mile run and
I thought to myself before the race that
exact thing like I think I can do it
but I'm never gonna know unless I sign
up for the race put myself in a position
where something incredible can happen or
not but I got to put myself in that
situation and now it's up to me like
will I get it done you know will what am
I willing to do am I willing to suffer
for that one day
for to have the next three decades have
that in my memory bank and have it on my
resume and and I will and I am willing
to do that and and I did so you know
what's really funny uh after you told me
that so I did a call with you the other
day to prep for the for the Pod say Hey
you know we're going to talk about I'm
thinking about talking about this this
and this you have any good stories and
you told me this this will verse can
thing and uh the next day my wife was
literally like she's like hey can you
take out the trash and I was like no no
baby
what's that about Canada
I will take out the trash and she has no
idea what I'm doing and I've been doing
it all weekend I've been because it's
once you see it it's actually everywhere
uh Ben texted Ben who's listening on
this thing right now he texted me this
morning he's like um
he's like hey how'd you eat this weekend
we're both like on a fitness kick he's
like can you stay locked in from now
till Thanksgiving and I just I was like
oh Ben you asking if we can
we don't ask canned questions anymore as
of meeting Jesse yitzler I no longer ask
can I it's will I or won't I that's it
well think about how many times in your
life someone said you you say something
that you've done like you know I did you
know rim to rim I'll take physical
activities or I climb Kilimanjaro and
you explain to someone like oh I can do
that
and I like my in the back of your head
you're like yeah you probably can but
you know will you do it you know there's
just like it's a huge difference between
like oh just checking the Box because
you said to yourself I can versus
actually going through and doing it by
the way Jesse I have one other story
that you you don't know about uh so you
used to go to something at least you
went once called coach K's Fantasy Camp
is that correct
I've been there for uh 18 straight years
okay okay perfect that's hilarious so
you went to this thing except for those
who don't know Coach K he was the the
greatest college basketball coach at
Duke I went to Duke and um my roommate
Trevor used to volunteer at Coach case
fantasy camp and volunteer was literally
volunteering I was like so what do you
you're staying over from brick because
it's like during some break and he's
like yeah I'm not going home I'm gonna
work this thing I'm like cool how much
you can pay because he's like I don't
think we really get paid but uh you know
whatever
like you just had put himself in a
position for something good to happen
and so he and what I did what he didn't
know and what I didn't know was the only
people who go to this camp that cost
like 10 grand to go to are basically
like business Ballers trying to like
live out their dream of like oh as if I
was an athlete and he's he so he all he
was doing was driving the shuttle back
and forth between where y'all were
staying and the thing and he's like dude
it's amazing he's like just hearing
these conversations what they're talking
about in this like nine minute shuttle
ride
he's like every night he would debrief
with me ideas that he heard he's like oh
this guy said that he does this this
thing over here this guy said he does
this and he told me he goes I met this
guy super charismatic like this guy he
loved this guy's energy he goes and he
tipped me 100 bucks for this like 10
minute shuttle ride and late I told him
he I told her I was mentioning to him
that you're coming on the potty he goes
that was the guy who tipped me so I
don't know if you remember this or not
but we took that tip and uh we had a
business idea at the time
and we needed to convince this uh famous
chef in LA to come fly out and partner
with us we had no money and so you you
plus a little like side job that I had
became the money we paid for for the
ticket to fly that guy out which
definitely changed the trajectory of our
life so little did you know I I love
that and um yeah I've been going there
for since I'm 35 it's for guys 35 and
older and it's not to chase some some
crazy Dream It's a combination of you
know
um meeting amazing people and also kind
of like there's not a lot of times I'm
55 so I'm older than you guys and
um I can't stop that clock you know at
times undefeated it's always ticking
it's it's the six days a year or the
five days I go there that I get to feel
like an eight-year-old again and it's
really one of the few times in my life
that I get that chance and I love it I
don't know man I follow you on Instagram
it seems like you live like an
eight-year-old a lot of times I'm pretty
sure
say that I'm pretty I'm pretty sure I
just saw you like in an RV with like
eight friends just like running around
like you yeah it seems like you got the
eight-year-old life kind of nailed down
I like to give myself that excuse Sam I
guess you but you're right it's more
than once more than five days a year
yeah I I think I think you've done that
all right you uh and then it was your
first
um kind of major business Marquee jet so
you went from did you go from Jingles to
Jets yeah so interestingly I had so the
jingle thing turned into a real business
I found that opportunity I started out
doing Jingles just for anyone that would
pay me anything to do anything so
um I was doing Jingles for like I I
honestly like turbo bubblegum this like
Bubble book gum company that no one ever
heard of like just anything that our
podcast intro needs a little sprucing up
if you wanna if you wanna dust it off
yeah I I got you guys and um and then I
start and then one of those Jingles gave
me an opportunity to write a theme song
for the New York Knicks I done a
commercial a radio ad for a company
called in the in the paint clothing it
was owned by
um Nancy grunfeld Ernie grunfeld the GM
of the Knicks wife and she really liked
what we had what I had done and she said
um yeah if you have any other ideas you
know let me know I said well I love to
do something for the next you know like
write a theme song and we could shoot a
video they can sing it in the arena so I
approached the Knicks to do this song
called donirco and
um the Knicks paid me four thousand
dollars to buy the song outright I'll
never forget it like
um Ashley borrowed money to go in the
studio to do this to do the song I
didn't have enough money to go in the
studio record it because they were
paying me 30 or 60 days later and by the
time I paid the studio the engineer the
lawyer that I had the singer the
producer it cost me forty eight hundred
dollars to actually deliver the song
that they were paying me four thousand
dollars for and when I look back on it
you know for most people they'd be like
that's a terrible business model it was
the best business model in the world for
me because when you start out you know
people buy into stories momentum and
people very often more than the products
like I was the business plan and I would
have paid the next 10 grand to say they
were my customer because once I had the
Knicks those phone calls to get unto the
other sports teams became very easy and
that became my calling card so I built a
business around that Sean that actually
I I ended up doing theme songs for
almost every professional sports team
and turned it into a business where we
were selling CDs like this thought I
would think the songs they play in the
arena add my original song with great
moments in the team history and sell
them at retail I sold that company to a
public company called sfx and that was
my first I was 27 we sold it for four
million bucks and then we had there was
an earn out for another 12 or 16 or
something which we earned out and that
was my first kind of like get off the
couch moment I was no longer on
Melissa's couch and I moved into my own
space what was your take home after that
I had a partner and at the end of the
day I think on the first four million I
made like a million and a half but by
the way a million and a half dollars to
me
all the money I was Elon Musk
before musk was born I was walking
around like I was musk like a million
and a half dollars I would owe to the
wake up at the eight and go to the ATM I
would get my print out of my balance
swear to God then I would wake up the
next morning and be like are you [__]
kidding me I have 300 more dollars than
I had yesterday and I was sleeping
my partner convinced me to take all 1.3
million dollars that we both cleared
after taxes or whatever it was
and reinvested to to get like exclusive
deals
in all this like we made the business
being reinvested in the business and
actually made the business a lot bigger
and we got our earn out and then then
everything changed a little bit for me
but you know I had no idea how to manage
money my parents never talked about
money my dad owned the plumbing supply
house my mom raised four kids the the
thing I had no relationship with money
that might sound weird but like
people talk about relationships with in
terms of their relationship with their
kids or their significant other but not
in terms of their relationship with time
which is very important and your
relationship with money which is equally
as important I had no relationship with
money
so when I got money I didn't know how to
save it how to spend it how to use it
how to act around it I was very immature
around new money and you know what
happened to me then I lost it because I
didn't know anything about it and
fortunately I was able to bounce back
through having other successful
businesses and failures but
no one ever told me about it how did you
lose it just overspending or what'd you
do
overspending thinking like oh that was
pretty easy man I could just I could do
that again you know
um what did you buy it wasn't like so
much what I bought it was just
you know helping my parents spreading it
out I wasn't abusive with it like but
just I didn't
know how to really handle that that's
pretty common right like you know Sean
and I have a bunch of friends that you
know we're both about 34 35 and we have
a bunch of friends and ourselves as well
who had exits at a young age and the
thing about selling a company it's
different than there's usually two types
of people I've noticed is people who
have cash flow businesses or they're
like a lawyer or something like that or
their own Law Firm something where your
like income is going up a nice amount
every year and you get used to having
that cash flow and then the other group
of people are typically young folks who
sell their company and typically those
people are like me where I paid myself
twenty thousand dollars to year one
twenty thousand dollars a year two year
three was fifty thousand dollars year
four I sell it and make a lot of money
and you're like this is just
overwhelming I don't know what to do
with this and that's like a pretty
that's like a pretty common thing is I I
don't think I don't know if most people
blow it but I think it takes about two
or three years to accumulate uh and kind
of get used to and learn what to do but
there's no one to teach you the problem
is I I'd always been taught
oh if you're a like a millionaire well
that ain't [__] was this no but I've
been no I've been taught the opposite
like if I saw a millionaire that was
like the Pinnacle like he's a
millionaire man so I always thought like
oh I have a million dollars that's all I
need to have for the rest of my life I'm
a millionaire at 27. and that's that was
the relationship that was wrong right
yeah you could spend that you could
spend that easy yeah you go and you have
a four thousand dollar dinner when you
were eating when I was basically eating
a 99 bagel for 17 years you know
things change quick you um I'm a big
believer that most of Life most of your
life kind of is a result of this the
conversation you have with yourself and
your head do you remember after you kind
of had that first hit and you see the
money and you still have you're only 27
you still got all your life ahead of you
do you at all remember like the
conversation you had with yourself like
all right Jesse so like now X and
whether X was a good good a good
conversation with yourself or misleading
one do you remember what what the
conversation you had with yourself at
that point in time was you know it was
interesting
because Sean I was living in New York
and most of my friends were working on
Wall Street they were working at hedge
funds they were making they were making
a lot of money around there was a lot of
money around me and you know it's very
easy to get caught up in what's he
making versus what am I making and it's
very easy to like you start having those
conversations with you yourself you can
go down and spiral downward very quickly
and you know what I was making what it
took me years to make and build and sell
and my journey to get to that point was
crazy I was selling Karen's celery
sticks door-to-door that didn't work I
had a t-shirt company that didn't work I
got dropped from a record label that
didn't work I cleaned meat drops that
didn't work I sold Chicken shrimp and
meat door-to-door that didn't work I
mean jingle company I it went on and on
so you know I had really worked so hard
and and at the same time like I invested
so much not for the money but just like
I just wanted to get a record deal man I
didn't care about the money I just want
everyone said you can't do it everybody
and it was it was such a driver if I
remember I listened to a podcast where
one of you guys with Laird Hamilton and
you were saying how that he was saying
how that you know one of you guys are
saying you need that anger to inspire
you like some kind of fuel you know so
um I had that
I still have that don't get me wrong I
still have that and I never want to lose
that Underdog mentality I never want to
be like I'm at the top of the mountain
I'm not I consider myself back of the
pack everything back of the pack sales
back of the pack entrepreneur there's so
many better entrepreneurs than me
um so many better salesmen than me but I
I but I love that feeling of I gotta
prove myself so when the money happened
it was just like oh Steve Stark is
making so much more than me we're in the
same basketball run like I got a cash
starter you know the um the Marquee jet
thing that's interesting though because
that's like totally out of left field so
and that seems like a a way bigger win
than the jingle business same partner
right same co-founder yeah same pointer
um it was a much bigger win and what
like most things in my life
um
most of the businesses that have
that I've been involved with weren't
plant you know and most of my successes
in life haven't been in my business plan
they've been opportunities that
presented themselves you know my whole
life I've been taught when opportunity
knocks you know and I'm not I don't want
to sit around waiting for opportunity to
knock I like to create my own my own
opportunity and I was a guest on a
private jet with my partner and I was
like you people fly like what is this
what is this that I'm on and we alleged
to some research like there's only
really two or three ways to fly
privately back in the 90s when we
started Marquee jet you can buy your own
airplane if you had 50 million dollars
you know or something like that well
that's out of the question you could get
a fractional
being a fractional program like netjets
but even that is a really big commitment
both in capital and time it's a
five-year commitment a lot of money up
front that wasn't I mean that wasn't an
option for us or you could Charter and
there were a lot of questions around
well who owns the plane who are the
pilots you know do I feel comfortable on
that what if the plane doesn't show up
so we found the little white space there
said you know we only want to fly like
25 hours a year I bet there's a lot of
people like us that don't want to own an
airplane don't want the responsibility
but they just want to be able to have
the um have a plane available on short
notice and that was the idea around
selling a 25 hour check card that will
work like a debit card so if if you and
if you and Sam Sean flew two hours you'd
have 23 hours left and then we partnered
with netjet Again part of being an
entrepreneur is figuring out how to get
from A to B the fastest
and for us for me in my life many times
it's been through partnership we've
partnered with netjets they ended up
buying us to use their airplanes
partnered with Coca-Cola it's ego at
zico Coconut order they ended up buying
us
um so but anyway that was that's what
happened we were guest on the plane and
you know
walking around eyes wide open looking
for opportunities and said wow this
could be really interesting and uh and
then started the Journey of figuring out
how we could pull this off because we
had no Aviation experience very little
money and you know I was younger than
you guys I was 28 29 years old and
um figuring out like man we need a lot
of airplanes where do we go for
airplanes and uh and then started that
journey of of building this company so
you walk in you walk into netjets and
you're like hey uh I'm Jesse former
rapper jingle entrepreneur and I would
like for you to give me your most
valuable assets your planes for this new
membership program how did you convince
them to do that
well at first we didn't they kicked us
out of the office in the first meeting
after about 12 minutes and um
backing that up the bigger question is
how we even get in the room
forget like what happened at the meeting
how in the world did a multi-billion
dollar company let two kids that didn't
break a thousand on their SATs into a
room to pitch them the idea a year
before that I was a yes guy my whole
life
I I was I I've kind of and I still try
to pride myself when people ask me for
things to deliver
if I can but never asked for anything in
return you know like I'm not like oh
Stan I'll do this for you Sean but like
can you do this from like I don't know
that's not the mo I got a call a year
before that from someone that said that
their daughter this is a true story and
it's the craziest story ever
this guy was having a his daughter was
having a sweet 16. and Chris um a famous
singer was performing in his hometown
his daughter wanted to bring his sweet
16 to the event the guy says I know you
know the manager can you help help this
guy get some tickets and do anything
special turns out I get the guy's
daughter as a backup singer for one song
with the mic off
everyone at school the next day is she's
like the hero of this like what happened
oh my God they're freaking out the guy
calls me up he goes I don't know who you
are I don't know what you have what you
do but you lit my daughter up and if you
ever need anything let me know like
turns out he I can't make this up he's
the president of that Jets a year later
I need 650 airplanes
at almost my gym you're never going to
believe this the guy you've got your
daughter on I have an idea for a thing
he gets to me the meeting we get thrown
out of the meeting 12 minutes in because
they're like we're not giving two kids
access to our 650 airplanes and this guy
Jim Jacobs comes up to me after the
meeting goes you know what that was
amazing I said we got thrown out in 12
minutes what do you mean he goes Rich
santuli my party he doesn't give anyone
12 minutes
because this thought that he'd come back
next week and bring this thing to life
re-pitch it I need more information so
we came back the next week and we
realized we could never sell them in a
PowerPoint which is like what everyone
guy sees 100 power points every year we
brought in our own focus group we had
eight people in the lobby and they
walked in one by one and they stood up
and said that they would never buy a
fraction of an airplane what netjets was
selling but they would buy a 25 hour jet
cart and at the end of the meeting they
literally said
if you guys raise money or put up your
own money if you can figure it out we'll
give you a shot in a a couple years
later we had more customers than that
yet that's crazy you showed him the
market you were like I could either put
up a chart or a pie chart right here or
I could literally walk the market into
the room and have them say I need this
product and it turns out that eight
people saying I need this product to
your face makes a bigger impact than a
pie chart that says 11 of the market
needs this when I think back on this
moment at 28 years old and we had like
Carl Banks from the New York Giants I
think Run from Run DMC was there it was
right behind me on the wall
um you know when he's got that meeting
yeah we brought him in we brought him in
and when we said when when we they got
up one by one and explained why this
card would work and you know I think
what they realized was they had been
pitching to a much older corporate
client and that they what they realized
I think in the meeting was here are
these two 27 year old kids and by the
way remember I said people buy into
people's stories and momentum
this had nothing to do with our product
the decision maker looked Us in the eye
and said I see enthusiasm
I see someone that's no matter what even
they even though they have no Aviation
experience is going to make this work
and I'm willing to bet on these two guys
it wasn't there was no PowerPoint it was
us like you're the business plan you are
the business plan so at the end of the
meeting he literally said to us after we
got the deal and you know like year one
we did I think we did like close to 200
million in sales Year One and I remember
going into his office and asking I said
Rich santulli who is like he knighted me
man he knighted me
I said rich how do we how do we end up
here man
and he looked me dead in the eye and he
goes you guys remind me of me when I was
27.
and bringing in this Focus Group
yes they came in and they explained
why they would buy a card and yes they
saw a much younger demo that someone
could be a lifetime customer now at 25
versus a lifetime customer 50. so they
saw the lifetime value of what we were
bringing in this younger generation of
athlete Entertainer you know young Mogul
Etc that they wanted that because that's
incredibly valuable to get that person
on their plane at a young age
but at the end of the day
they he saw something in my penny and I
my partner and I that he wanted a bet on
and you know I just want to say this for
anyone listening here because I know
this is primarily a business podcast by
the way it took me 37 minutes to warm up
but now I'm fully here
he's here I'm
saying but I got it now
um you know
like I said that was never in our
business plan oh we're gonna bring in
our own focus group to start a company
that does 5 billion in sales
it's like it's the things that live off
the business plan that make the biggest
difference and when you have a chance
you know you don't get a lot of big
meetings like that and I remember at 27
walking in there and saying to my
partner like this is as big as a guess
because you know what there is no one
else that is 650 airplanes this is it
and um
you have to bring that meeting to life
you have to stand out you have to you
know not in a gimmicky way
but you have to make that memorable man
and and fortunately we were able to do
that and it worked and then we had an
amazing amazingly fruitful relationship
and partnership with netjets until we
exited
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
all right everyone a quick break you're
listening to this episode you've maybe
listen to a bunch of MFM episodes we get
a lot of interesting insights and the
reason we get insights is I have a lot
of peers and friends who are CEOs of
companies and I'm able to ask them all
types of different questions and it all
started because I used to run this event
called hustlecon and I would like
convince these speakers of big startups
you know you've probably heard of most
of these companies the founder of
grammarly we work Away Travel Casper all
these cool companies and I would sit in
a green room with them and I would hear
all these amazing stories but I would
also be able to learn like how to fire
someone effectively how to how to handle
things when the business isn't going
well how to handle things when it's
going great like all these stuff that
happens behind closed doors and it
changed my life and so I started this
company it's called Hampton
joinhampton.com is the URL where we make
it really easy to have a peer group and
have a network of other entrepreneurs
that are like you similar Industries
similar size companies and so if you do
run a company
check it out the average company is
doing about 25 million in Revenue some
companies go all the way up to two three
four hundred million in revenue and
they're publicly traded others are a
little bit smaller and the one two three
four range but my partner and I Joe we
review every single interview and we
hand carry and hand select all these
interesting people so it's been a really
wonderful community
so if you want to be a little less
lonely if you want to find information
and insights that you can't Google check
it out it's Hampton that's the name of
the company and joinhampton.com is the
URL
so you should check it out I review all
the interviews so uh enjoy the rest of
the episode are you um so like I I I
think that all three of us might be a a
bit similar in in business relationships
where we're like we bring the passion
and some of the creativity and the zero
to one stuff were you good at running
that company or were you or did you have
a good partner who is running it and you
were great at kind of bringing some of
the deals to fruition I can only run
marathons I can't run any business I'm
not good at running anything no I'm a
terrible operator I'm a terrible manager
but I'm really good at knowing that I'm
terrible at that and being okay with it
so
you know we were able to hire a CEO
right away
um and then which allowed me to focus on
sales which I was which I was better at
Buzz which I was really good before the
ins before Instagram I'm not so good at
the up now with Instagram but back when
there was no Instagram I was good at
creating priable opportunities and and
talk worthy events and um for my hero
that was really important so no
um I have never I've never been the CEO
of a business I've never ran or operated
business but I've been a Founder I think
five times and how'd that model work is
it like a Costco model where you were
breaking even on the 200 million in
sales but you made money off the uh a
membership no so we
the original deal with netjets was we
were leasing time on their planes but I
wouldn't have to we wouldn't have to
enter into a long-term lease until we
sold it so we had no rest they were
carrying all the paper so if I bought if
you and if Sam Sean you guys bought 100
hours we go by 100 hours and it was
marked up so we were just a marketing
organization they owned and operated the
planes and we were releasing it as we
got big all of a sudden you know we have
four thousand members were doing a
billion dollars a year
then the model changed and we had to
start buying our airplanes but by that
time we had you know significant cash
and we were able to do that so it
started off with literally it was an
incredible deal for us and for that
um it was a true
um no lose for both parties and those
headline numbers are really big how big
was that exit I mean that's a that's a
pretty big thing how big is netjets I
don't even know
uh I don't even remember what netjet
sold to Berkshire for I'm sure it's
public this was before Berkshire owned
it is that right
that just sold at the Berkshire prior to
us and then and then we went to now
we're part of that part of Nashville
which is your Berkshire stock because
that would have been a good stock to
just get in the deal
I know right no we didn't netjets sold
for 7.25 725 million and 98. and half of
it was paid in stock so that was um if
if that was a good deal for netjets
depending on if I don't know what the
revenue was but that's a lot of money
you um you snapped your fingers and you
were like uh we did first year we did
whatever I forgot what you said 200
million or something 200. I don't know
what that means what is 200 million
there that's not that can't be
membership dudes that's that would be
insane no it did yeah no because there
are our average our average customer
spent close I think it was 250 or 235
000 a year gotcha okay but and it's more
like uh gmv so because you have to so
your take is some spread between that
and then whatever okay gotcha so yeah I
guess like on on that model what's the
income on 200 let's just say 100 million
what what can your profit be on that
well this is 30 years ago so how about I
don't remember exactly what it was but
it was enough that I was now off the
couch and living a very good life and uh
and by the way the best Roi in that deal
is I met my wife there she was a
customer of ours and that's how I met my
wife
um you you said you told me something
which was about getting the first
customers so before your wife was even a
customer uh you know you're like I'm on
this plane I'm like holy [__] this is an
amazing way to fly I'd love to do this
I'm sure other people would love to do
this you come up with the idea cool
now how do you go get those first people
to give you two hundred thousand dollars
to be a part of this right that's like a
huge like where did you go find those
customers and and tell the story of kind
of how you got it off the ground
well we were start we started out you
know I think the first thing that any
entreprene most entrepreneurs is at
least in our position and
more keychain is we had to establish
credibility because if I was going to
sell you time on a plane
and you said who flies with who flies
with you guys that would be my first
question or one of them and I said well
my dad and my next door neighbor you
probably would leave but if I was like
you know Oprah Bill Clinton you'd be
like wow they must have vetted this you
know so we started out looking for
athletes entertainers and and high
profile people
um which was not easy for me
um but I had to go where wealthy people
congregated and I heard about this you
know they could afford time on the jet I
heard about a conference in Monterey
California that was just getting some
traction called tent so I flew out to
Monterey and um you know I told the guys
like hey I'm gonna go get my first sale
I'm going to the thing called a TED Talk
they were like what
it's in Monterey California you gotta
like you can't even get there you have
to like as connected through Chicago
into whatever rented a car five hours of
Monterey I get to the 10. it's like Fort
Knox man everybody has a credential like
this like huge and I'm like you need a
credential to get in here
there's no credentials to be found so
I'm thinking like how am I gonna sneak
in buy someone's pass like go into the
room where all the qualified leads are
I'm in this coffee shop plotting like
you know my my entrance or how I'm gonna
do it and every two hours the wave of
people come in and they're buying they
have these credentials I'm like oh this
is where they come on their break and
they're all buying lattes and muffins
and these lattes and muffins and
whatever
lattes and muffins so the next morning I
got up at five and I bought all the
muffins from this I controlled all the
muffin inventory in Monterey California
and I literally just waited in this is a
True Story by the way and it's it's been
verified you can walk so two hours later
this guy uh the first wave of people on
the break walk in and the guy orders a
latte and a muffin I stop them uh they
tell them that they could give them a
latte but they're all out of muffins
It's like [__] nine in the morning
it's like you're out of muffins the guy
starts walking I stop I'm like sorry I
overheard you
I actually have an extra muffin if you
want a muffin
and uh he's like you got an extra muffin
I'm thinking like I got every single
[__] Muppet under the table man what
do you need and um I started talking to
him he's like you know what are you I'm
here for the conference I'm like me too
what do you do I tell them what I do he
said you gotta be kidding me I'm in the
market for a private jet cart and his
name is Josh koppelman he owned a
company called half.com famous VC right
now he is I bumped into him like three
years ago at uh at a retreat and and we
were we were talking about this and
anyway he was my first sale
he was my first Dale and and that is not
a story of me being a good sales rep
because like I said I am truly back of
the pack but it is an example of me
putting myself in a situation will verse
can
of putting myself in a situation where I
could attract that kind of luck you know
and and um he was my first sale though
she wanted to answer your question and
and you know what happened after that
I'm gonna tell you what happened after
that I service the hell out of them
I did what everybody listening would do
but I did 30 more so when he went to
Mexico he expected me to return his call
and the every em DM and all that of
course I did what everyone here would do
but he went to Mexico he didn't expect a
list of Pediatricians that I've added in
case his kids got sick he didn't expect
me to make reservations every Wednesday
at every night at eight o'clock during
spring break in Mexico in case he and
his wife wanted to go to dinner and and
and after a couple of months of doing
that what he didn't expect me to do he
gave me the magic word
he gave me a referral
and that was rinse and repeat for for
five years until we grew this so no I
was never the CEO I was never the the
operator I was never the CEO I was I
wasn't even I don't even think I was on
the org chart so I'm I'm looking at your
check this out well you're on the
website I'm looking at I use web archive
I'm looking at the uh the 2005 version
of marqueejet.com and I'm looking at
your about page and what's interesting
it looks like your senior executive team
was not only awesome it was like amazing
because Ken Austin I see was your
executive VP is that the same Ken Austin
that went and started is it Avion the
tequila company and most recently
started proper 12 with Conor McGregor is
is that the same Ken Austin and the
tequila company with the rock yes you've
done a good job of hiring no we were the
Boston Celtics man we were the Boston
Celtics we
from like the old we the
Talent
at this company
was
exceptional Ken Austin
is an exceptionally I don't it could be
them is such a talented
Guy and um I learned so much from Ken
and you know we had great sales reps and
we attracted really good talent because
we built a really good culture well it's
also a sick product I mean you said you
met your wife there it's like that's
like the greatest line ever like oh dude
you're here at this jet company so I
know like you're of someone I know
you're someone interesting definitely
just so it happens I I work here or I
own the company I mean it's like a
that's that's a it's a pretty uh
wonderful experience I imagine to work
at a private jet company it was it
really was and you nailed it but the
only thing I would say to that is I
think there were like 65 private jet
companies that put a flag in the ground
from when we started to when we sold and
I think we were the only one that made
money I might be wrong about that but if
something some including uh Garrett Camp
the guy from Uber he created he tried to
do an Uber for jets uh that didn't work
out right it's it's very very difficult
and if we didn't have netjets as a
partner I you know it wouldn't I'm sure
it wouldn't have worked as well so a lot
a lot things lined up they're the
business you did a partnership on was
zico coconut water and yeah I think this
is interesting because now we're seeing
a pattern the first is you're picking
businesses in like categories that
they're not in the NBA curriculum
nobody's thinking about oh sports teams
need slogans and CDs that will increase
their fandom nobody even realizes that
that's a niche that you can go into or
to do you know this membership model for
private jets nobody's even looking in
that area at the time right there's a
very few people are even thinking about
that Niche it's not common then you go
coconut water so now your consumer
package Goods in a beverage category
that's non-existent really at the time
um and I think zico was pretty small
when you found it it's not like it had
like you know tons of momentum
um so talk about two things number one
finding these niches like what what is
it that you what is your operating
philosophy that leads that seems to
consistently lead you to these that's
the first question and the second is the
key partnership that got it off the
ground I heard an amazing Matt Damon
story I want to hear the full version of
it
yeah yeah
I spent a year trying to figure out how
to have my own coconut water company I
went to Brazil I went to Jamaica what
trying to figure out this is there were
no there was no coconut water in the
stores that this is I'm gonna so let me
back it up even further I was running
100 mile race
and I did a lot of trick when I was
doing my training I did a lot of
research around hydration and nutrition
if I'm going to run for arguably 24
hours how many calories do I need to eat
drink an hour
um how many calories do I need to take
in an hour how much fluid ounces do I
need to drink an hour how much salt do I
need an hour and my research led me to
coconut water
so I ran this race powered by coconut
water and I finished it in 22 hours and
30 minutes when I was done I'm like this
is going to be this is the new Gatorade
no one knows about this I'm the human
guinea pig
I'm bringing this to Market you know
it's a better option it's all natural
one ingredient you know it rains God
sends it up a tree we crack it open and
we drink it like this is
I mean are you kidding me
so I spent a year trying to figure it
out how to import it and I realized like
I did get a 980 on my SAT because I
couldn't figure it out
but I knew I could market and sell it I
knew I could so again same model same
formula I took it the idea to Coca-Cola
the president of Coke's emerging Brands
division
um was friends with one of my customers
at Marquis Jack he got me a meeting
I pitched the meaning
uh in the meeting I pitched this idea of
coconut water
he takes the liking to me but he says we
don't buy PowerPoints or Coca-Cola
we buy Brands he goes but if you partner
with another company or something you
know maybe we can then out that's out
there that has proved that they can make
the product ship the product get it in
stores or whatever we'll come in we'll
partner with you so I went to zico and
that's how we formed the partnership
during the meeting the um about a week
before I was at
um Matt Damon's house and Matt was also
a customer of a marquee Jet and I did
the things that I did for Josh koppelman
with Matt and we became friends and I
said to Matt you know he'd asked me if I
wanted to spend the night they were
going out and I said I'm going to Brazil
in a day or two I can't see because what
are you doing in Brazil I said I'm
starting a coconut water business
he's like you got to be kidding he's
like I love coconut I have a coconut
tree in my backyard
he's like I drink he goes if anything
happens what you know with this company
let me know I may want to get involved
a month later in the meeting at Coke
like the meeting is going so bad I'm
showing this PowerPoint you know like
and out of nowhere like I know I had
achieved the whole energy
I just turned to the president the guy
at cooking I'm like you know my partner
Matt Damon and I and the guy
that team is your partner I said I
didn't mention that what are you talking
about
we go all the way to the one yard line I
leave and I call man I'm like man I need
a favor
he's like I'm like can I come over with
the cat can we climb up your tree get a
coconut chop it open you know go in the
kitchen put a straw in it you know um
turn to the camera and say muttar mutar
Kent the CEO of coke there's got to be a
better way than this he's like
all right and I filmed this he filmed
this award-winning
friggin
35 second short film of him getting a
coconut chopping it open and saying
there's got to be a better way and and
we got the deal and the creek you know
what's interesting about that is
obviously Who's Gonna Get You know a
mega star to come that's not the point
it's it goes back to what I said
um will you make it work
putting yourself in a situation where
you can get lucky here's the other
pattern Sean you're talking about
patterns and making me making yourself
stand out and be memorable in a meeting
now I stretched it a little with this
one but but
um but it ended up it ended up working
out
that's an amazing story that's amazing
that's a good one I love that story I
love that story you that's wild I like
Coke bought it two years later 100 did
you uh when you bought did you buy into
zico at the time like did you uh was
that like yeah and have you made bets
that you felt like Financial bets that
were risky like you know Elon does this
thing where he sort of rolls all the
proceeds into the next business and sort
of re goes all in each time which is you
know probably not advisable to most but
like what's your strategy been now that
you have some chips to play with do you
do you make big Financial bets are you
saying no no I'm going to add value
strategically do you start things from
scratch what do you what do you like to
do with the chips that as you accumulate
them how do you how have you used that
to to your advantage
well I realized that I've got as I've
gotten older that more isn't better
better is better and I really don't make
a lot of bets I have four kids
um what I'm most proud of Sean in my
journey at 55 is that I've been I've
I've exited five businesses but I've
been able to keep
build a family keep my health you know
be a really good son to my parents
um I have great friends so I really
aren't I'm not uh and I'm not using Eli
as an example you brought him up not me
but I'm not trying to roll everything in
or
um I'm really proud of what I've been
able to do and I'm really proud of the
life that I built so I really don't I
really say no to Mo I have this thing
at this point in my life if it's high
aggravation for high reward I'm not
doing it if it's and that goes for
anything money friends I don't want High
aggravating friends I'm on friend
reduction right now come on friend
reduction Man follow a low aggravation
you're doing layoffs you do Zoom calls
so people let them know hey I'm sorry we
had to make a reduction in in France
yeah excuse me Mr David can you stop on
my office
there's a severance package three more
times that's it we need to have a
discussion
that's correct that's so fun but I'm not
trying to you know push you really it's
like it's based on in food my enthusiasm
for something
um how's it going to impact my life
meaning like day to day
um I walked away from several ideas that
I think could be really good because
you're like just because you have a good
idea it doesn't mean you should do it
and I've um
Sarah said that to me I had an idea
now I see people doing it now about
eight years ago I said Sarah I have an
idea that's bigger than Marquee jet like
Marquis jet was the biggest thing I've
done you know and um
I walked you through it and she goes
that's an incredible idea don't do it
what was it I wanted to take commercial
this is going back eight years ago so
now it might sound like oh well people
are doing it now I actually pitched this
to a major airline
now
um it's doing it
but I wanted to make commercial travel
feel like private travel
for people I felt like there was a bit
and there still is an opportunity for
people that would pay up
to fly commercial
but they want an experience that's more
private so for example if I'm flying
from New York to California
and I'm by myself and I'm on a global or
a Gulf Stream and I'm going round trip
that's an expensive flight man that is
an expensive flight
um where I could just buy a first class
ticket for maybe 1500 bucks
so instead of let's say that that flight
cost me if you chartered it maybe it's
gonna cost you let's just say fifty
thousand dollars it might be more it
might be I have no I don't even know
today what it is
but
I could spend fifty thousand dollars on
a private flight
which is amazing or I could buy a first
class ticket for 1500 bucks I as a
fifteen hundred dollar ticket holder
would gladly give you another fifteen
hundred dollars United American Delta
Frontier whoever if you could walk me
through a back door and make me feel
like Mick Jagger and escort me onto the
airplane it through the bath door
and um no one was doing it no one was
doing it and now they are doing stuff
like that and that's smart it's like you
like unbundled the private experience
it's like okay there's the jet part of
it but then there's the walk-on to the
plane walk off the plane okay because
when once you get on an airplane do you
really care yeah it doesn't matter I'm
in 1A no one's bothering me in 1A and in
some regard the commercial jet is safer
you have more amenities so yeah like but
I've been on a
I flew first class uh from New York to
LA one time for like some meeting I
would I had never flown first class but
I did it because I had was overnight and
I had to be ready for a meeting and I
get on I was 1A and one B are sitting
right next to me with Stephen A Smith
and I was like how the [__] do you go to
the plane before me and I like looked it
up and apparently there is like a
private door I guess if you're famous uh
what what is that
well I think now several Airlines have
it and there's services that do it
outside of the airlines as independent
services but my point is
so I had the idea but I also felt like I
had the buy side that I could deliver to
the airline because you know I'm
involved with them with some NBA players
and
um I'm part owner of the Atlanta Hawks
and I so I have I have and my friends
are all doing really well that are
they're all doing really well I thought
we'd want to have this service so I had
the idea and a significant part of the
buy side to package together to an
airline to bring private fires onto
their Mothership which is the domestic
part of their travel but um but anyway
to answer your question so things like
that good ideas lucrative but does but
for me at that point in my life
to put I'd be on I don't know if I have
the energy
to do it's going to take away from
Tuesday's flag football game I'm not
doing it and I don't know if I had that
if I still have I don't I don't still
have that well you you but you can't
turn that switch off right because I saw
you on Instagram like you know I don't
know a year ago or six months ago or
something like that and you were like
pickles it's yeah you're like uh guys
pickles and you know it seemed like you
know the guy who was saying coconut
water when nobody was talking about
coconut water he's talking about pickles
so me and me and Ben started paying
attention we're like hey what's Jesse
it's done with Pickles
well okay he's kind of right yeah no
Brandon pickle and so describe this
pickles opportunity that you see now
currently this is present day now right
we're done with the past now we're
talking present and future
um what do you see in the pickle market
well like 245 million Americans eat
pickles every year it's like 75 of our
population eat pickles and again it goes
back to the to our running conversation
I'm starting to see at races
pickles at the con at the at the aid
stations they never existed 10 years ago
pickle juice never existed 10 years ago
at at the aid stations of marathons and
your local files
yeah so that made my intention was that
it has a lot of salt in it when I grew
up all my black friends would say that
they would drink pickle juice in order
to avoid a hangover oh yeah in Russia
it's a it's a you know it's a big remedy
for hangovers but my point is like it
put my antennas up but what is this you
know just like when I saw the first
thing of coconut water on the Shelf of
like what the hell is this I just ran
100 I'm gonna so so I started doing so I
started thinking about it and I'm like
you know what
I can't even name three pickle companies
and I I love pickles I don't even know
by the way this is the part where he's
gonna bring in a focus group of 10
people and he's gonna say okay they have
a pickle company and nobody could do it
and he's gonna be like that's the
business plan well listen so I I
researched like the seven best tasting
pickles
and of the seven best tasting pickles I
think it was like
uh The Today Show did something you know
it's like it's like someone incredible
did it
um
I only knew one cup one of the companies
so I'm like if I only known one of this
top seven best tasting pickles there's a
problem in the marketing of pickles it's
a marketing problem and I'm a good
marketer
so in it that's where it started and I'm
like
this is a category with no innovation no
fun
you know 75 percent of Americans eat
pickles the average American eats like
10 pounds a year that's more than cereal
and I'm like
I like it here I like this space
I'm a pickle guy too Jesse saying is it
Clawson like the big brand is that right
I like Clawson I like Mount Olive is it
called a valsik or Vlasic I like that
company but I think Mount olives is the
biggest ones I always get the little
ones that look like a witch's toe are
you wearing a metal out of the pickle
shirt
I'm convinced in fact we're texting Mr
Beast right now we're we're gonna come
into this Market too you you just made a
mistake my friend you're we're bringing
our our influencers into this Market I I
believe you on this opportunity why do
that let's just let's get the beast on
the phone let's party with the beast
beast pickles that's right that's right
who thinks about David
yeah where's David I need it go get Ben
Affleck he seems like a good pickle guy
I need to talk about Feast is low
aggravation though I only want a low
aggravation yeah well I don't know about
that one Mount Olive does uh 220 million
in Revenue a year privately owned that
sounds it sounds doable man sounds like
our money right guys yeah yeah I want to
thank them very much for holding it for
us yeah
shoot a text over the CEO of all of them
to keep that money warm for us all right
we'll be there soon
what other ideas you got because I I
told you I was saying you know uh you'll
get this because you know you're uh you
know you're a rap guy when you go on
certain shows like The Breakfast Club or
sway in the morning there's like an
expectation like okay if you come out
here you gotta freestyle and we're
trying to do that of the business realm
where it's like you come out here you
got to bring fresh ideas you can't just
only talk about your history and you go
you tell me you go I got 50 ideas in my
top drawer that's all right say no more
but you hinted at me by the way uh the
the pickle names sound like a rap name
sweet gherkin bread and butter kosher
dill like this these are all rap names
man yeah yeah we're about to have this
pickles
um all right tell me tell me about this
idea you gave me three words I don't
know what the idea is but you said
ready-made eight ounce drinks what you
got in mind
yeah so I mean I I've been accumulating
ideas in my in my top drawer for 35
years
um
I love starting thems Sean you know but
um yeah that I mean I don't I don't mind
by the way if you guys want to rub
anyone wants to run with this you can
I'll take a one penny royalty I'll give
it to charity
um you know I think like I go back to
Five Hour Energy
the brilliest of Five Hour Energy is
they took a you know 12 ounce uh energy
drink they Shrugged it down to two and a
half ounces right that's what five RNG
was and
why did it work they they only I believe
I believe they only are predominantly
sold stores that would put it on the
countertop when they started out so like
it wasn't buried at GNC on the bottom
shelf and it was like on the countertop
at checkout impulse Buy
they were selling 10 million two and a
half bottle ounce bottles every week 10
million
when I look at when you look around
retail
at the counter at checkout of retail the
countertop is incredibly crowded and if
you go to Whole Foods there's gum
there's mints there's this there's that
there's chocolates Everywhere You Go gas
stations there's lottery tickets and
then that the only place that I found
like where there's open area or liquor
stores if you go into a liquor store you
don't see the the the the the the self
stink you know the stands and the
crowded space and all the tchotchkes and
stuff that you see at gas stations and
at grocery and and other retailers and
um I think there's a tremendous
opportunity I was gonna call them
quickies
um to have like ready-made shots
same thing as as five like of you lemon
drop whatever your favorite Kamikaze
ready-made drinks are right at the
countertop that are already made fresh
ingredients you know where people could
just come and grab and go and have a
ready-made cocktail that they can bring
to tailgates parties
Etc I'm not saying it's gonna it's gonna
be a great Goose vodka but I see an
opportunity and if not that someone
should go make a deal and and in a very
fragmented okay now you got me thinking
Sean now I'm like this wasn't even on my
radar here we go it's like the
freestyling stuff you were talking about
I was playing with that
um really even a better idea would be to
go
liquor stores are that is the most
fragmented Market out there they're all
Mom and Pops there's no like chain of
liquor I mean like you know you go to
your local liquor stores like the guy my
neighbor owns a liquor store I go there
and I get the wine and this and that
do a roll up go pay someone for go rent
the countertops of all the liquor stores
and then go to Nabisco or one of the big
boys and be like hey guess what I want
ten thousand countertops
you want to put your widget there
you want to put your [__] widget
there
keep the money yeah keep the money
[Laughter]
I love it yeah probably we could
probably talk for 15 minutes about the
opportunity and come up with 10 ideas
around that you know that's where it
starts it starts with just like bad idea
or better idea the idea
exactly exactly uh you're kind of like I
think the background of rap I'm not I'm
not joking about this I think the the
way the brain can sort of like not
censor itself and wait till it has a
fully formed perfect idea but actually
just start to go and then know that oh
I'm gonna hop from this to this to this
or this and there yeah that'll be the
line and that's all I need to do is get
to that one that one line I'm gonna show
you this too this is this is something
I'm selling now this is I don't know are
we on are we still on YouTube
no or video video This Is by 2024 all
planned out this is next year
fully almost fully baked what my year
looks like my race is what's orange
there's a lot of orange on that what
does orange stand for orange orange are
so when Sarah sold spanked she wanted to
do a lot of traveling so this year we
committed as a family to go on the road
so all the orange as crazy as this looks
is all travel wow we're going to Africa
we're going to New Zealand but it's all
mapped out yellow what's it what's
yellow and what's what's green or blue
whatever that is yellow on my races and
events green is my speaking uh Green is
oh birthday is this stuff
this thing's dope not blue I wanted to
ask you about this because you are super
legit as far as like what you've
actually been able to accomplish your
level of success
and you do stuff like this you have like
the big ass calendar club or whatever
it's like that thing is called big-ass
camera that's a product you make it's
like a course you have and
um I've always surprised that you're
doing those things and you know what
what's your thought process on like or
the running club or the running club
like how do you pick projects yeah I
mean I think this goes back to the
earlier question you asked me about
reinvesting in other businesses and
stuff like that
um how old are you guys how old are you
Stan 34. I'm 35. so I got I got two
decades on you guys
um and but I got I got the most
experiential decades I believe on you
guys if the 40s and 50s 30s 40s 50s
um
you know
for me
there's
I'm in a coaching space you know um
um
I speak a lot I have coaching programs
the calendar but even the events that I
do the running races and this kind of
stuff it all has an element of getting
people to do more than they thought to
inspire people to do more than they
thought they could but but to answer
your question and the reason why I just
said that is
um
the gal works with us in our family
office was looking at all the businesses
and
um and asking me like I don't have a
sales rep on my payroll I don't I'm not
going crazy on the marketing and this
and that and it's really word of mouth
and she looked at the numbers and she's
like you know do you want to scale this
and what are you doing why don't you
just go do the liquor idea or the
airplane idea or this idea or that idea
or any of the ideas in your draw and I
pulled out my phone
and I said Kendall
all these are from today
all of these messages are for today pick
one
read it I said I can't and it was like
you changed my life or this has really
inspired me or you you know I did this
or I saw my parents I haven't seen my
parents in a long time and you know I
talk about the importance of that very
often you know about not losing sight of
what you already have while you're
chasing your entrepreneurial dream your
health your family your friends there's
no business in the world that would give
me the return on investment that I'm
getting right now there's nothing I
could do what build another Marquee jet
work 20 hour days
I mean like that's not going to give me
that sense of impact Legacy for my kids
um and just the feeling quite honestly
that I have I mean like it's
Indescribable a wire is a wire
you get the wire and it's like
the same feeling you get
when when you sell a business
is the same feeling you get when you
finish the marathon you walk an old lady
across the street or you do anything
that makes you feel good about yourself
I swear to God and I have the right to
say that because I sold five of them
I have the right to say that it's the
same feeling and for the for for very
very for a lot of people chasing that
waiting 20 years to sell a business or
something to have that feeling when I
feel like I get that every single day
and that's a really powerful place to be
in your life at 55. and and that's the
reason man and and so you're right I
have these businesses and you know
there's no real plan around them people
like what you would I don't I don't know
I'm just enjoying
how it's making me feel right now and
what's wrong with that I got a scale
just to scale because everyone told me I
had to scale
I don't want to do that man right I did
that so a question that we like to ask
people is it's a really simple question
but we we learn a lot which is like what
do you do with your money so like you
have a really interesting lifestyle I
agree with you I'm not I don't like the
Elon Musk path of uh all these
sacrifices and uh
um doing things for the sake of humanity
I'm like I'd rather have a fun life and
you have a really sick life I mean I I
I'm I'm a former College athlete Runner
so I I like watching what you're doing
um and I like to work out and do these
podcasts and have a lot more fun than
just work what do you do with your money
um and
um when you're financing it this are you
just are you using your speaking fees to
finance it and then you have your
Marquee jet money in just one big
account in the in the markets how's your
portfolio set up and what are you doing
with your money
we'll just you know it's um
I don't know man like we we never
really think about it that much I know
it's I don't want to belittle it or
sound
in any way a noxious in fact I'm
incredibly grateful but like it goes
back to the relationship with money from
the beginning of the conversation
um we're not trying to triple it or
quadruple our money like we don't really
think about it it's like it's spread out
strategically and
we live our life what's your monthly
burn I mean what what does one need to
spend uh per month to do that
I like to ride my bike
I like to run
I like to swim I like to speak in public
I like to be around my family and
friends
what whatever that cost me Sam
is what I'm gonna spend on it
how's that for an answer
yes ma'am
uh I want to ask you about something
that you have talked about that I really
liked which is uh around your life
philosophy so you have a few of these
that have made an impact on me you um I
don't know where I saw some Tick Tock
clip or something you were talking about
like this three minute daily thing you
go three minutes and I forgot exactly
how you phrase it but it was like you go
I I can Network in three minutes right I
I can I can invest in my friends my my
network in in just three minutes a day
and I'm always interested in anything
that's like you know six minute abs I I
I tend to be interested in the like you
know shorter time frame type things and
you go compliments what was the other
ones you go compliments
um complimenting congratulating
explain that that philosophy because
I've been doing that now where I I
basically go through my text list and
I'm like who's somebody I could
compliment boom send it out and they
love it because they're like uh you know
I'm thinking of them we haven't talked
in a little while it's really simple for
me to do this is like kind of like a
actually like a very effective little
tip I want you to share with here
well in my 20s I didn't have a way to to
I had no I was really on it super tight
budget I was writing 10 handwritten
letters I went a year
not every single day but pretty much
writing about 10 handwritten letters a
day and that was my entire marketing
strategy and I realized that you know
it's a great way to get through the
Clutter of email DMS so you know all
this stuff because a lot of people don't
check their emails or their assistant
does or whatever but everyone reads a
handwritten letter
so I the three minutes a day is you know
I had sent the text you mentioned the K
Academy Coach K I sent a uh fluent to
Carolina
um not too long ago and I said coach a
text thanking him for having the event
and I said you don't need to respond I
just want to let you know like it makes
me feel like an eight-year-old for five
days a year I want to thank you for for
doing this I know you'd have to do it
and it took and like I realized like he
might share that with his team like
we're having an impact like look at look
at this note or tell his wife he might
do nothing but now if I see Coach K I
have permission to go over them and say
coach I send you a text like I don't
know if you got it but like I have that
permission to do it I'm not coming out
of left field like oh hey coach you know
like well you just so that took me 45
seconds to hit send write it and it's
then so I was like okay if I did three
of those a day
and just took three minutes and just
started hitting friends suppliers
manufacturers inflict whatever
over the course of a year often that
thousand
I will plant a thousand permission slips
all over the country and world
three minutes a day so in carpool line
when I take my kids to school or pick
them up I just fire off a couple of
emails or call them or whatever so that
was that theory the compliment
congratulated consoling is really just
kind of three things that I I like to to
remind myself to do to maintain and
build authentic relationships authentic
relationships not relationships
authentic relationships so for example
if you have somebody in your life that's
grieving
and you'd all reach out to them and you
guys are young but you'll see in the
next 10 years friends will start to get
diagnosed with stuff parents
grandparents are going to pass away like
your life's Gonna Change man if you have
someone that's grieving and you don't
reach out to them they will never forget
it build a nip oh you can't human nature
you can't even help but take inventory
who reached out and who did you're just
aware
I just lost my father I know everybody
that called me I know everybody that
didn't call me and the people that
didn't call me don't get a pass
they don't get a pass
so you always want to consult the people
that you know something happens to a
friend in your life that's great you
want to congratulate them you know and
then you want to compliment you know
Sean man Sam listen you guys have an
amazing podcast you did it yourself you
know you guys decided to like sold some
businesses and here you are you know
bringing on aspiring people to inspire
entrepreneurs all over the world and um
I just want to congratulate you on your
success man I'm not you know I you just
call someone out of nowhere your default
to calls or texts either way I just
think
I personally like handwritten letters
here's one
um because I feel like the intent
it takes a little longer but to actually
get a stamp lick it go to the mailbox
put it in the mailbox it's received
completely different than just sent
but you know so by like in the pecking
order but you don't have the ability to
do that it takes too long but at the end
of the year I do like to write
25 to 50 handwritten thank you letters
every year I have a whole closeout the
year process that I kind of teach people
but like and that's one of them you know
but you compliment you graduating
console and you do that to people and
like if I say I'm if I hit you up God
forbid you had something bad and and I
don't even know I just met you for the
first time
other than the question about how my
birth rate I love you
so if I if I were to follow you up after
one meeting and say stand man I heard
about XYZ
man I'm so sorry that happened to you
and then four months later I'll call you
up and say sam and you guys just hit 5
million downloads a day
congratulations man
and then I call you up against the end
of the year I said Sam I just want to
let you know man that question you asked
me about about my burn rate you know I
would rethought it and I want to
compliment you because you ask the tough
questions and you know what that's the
seat that you're in and I give you
credit for asking questions like that to
people on the other end and I really
admire you for that I do those three
things in that year you're going to
think differently about oh you'll be his
hero
you'll be all of our heroes to be honest
with you that'd be incredible all right
well Dad
Sean you laugh about that when we're
laughing about it but let me ask you a
question
who doesn't want to be a hero
you're right who doesn't want to be here
we like if you tell me I don't have to
run into a building and save save
someone I can just do that and I could
be a quote unquote hero like you know
what I built my career doing that well
so this is about relationships you also
have others about skill Building Life
Experiences explain some of your other
kind of Life rules because I think these
are really worth sharing you know people
I think will be entertained and inspired
by the business stories but my hope is
that that actually was just buying the
right to drop a little wisdom on them at
the end here because this is the stuff
I've liked the most from you from your
story
um so so tell talk about you know the
sort of musogi or the the Kevin's rule
like these are pretty foundational
yeah well that goes into kind of the
planning that I showed you on the
calendar and
um I really do do two or three things
every year
um at the beginning of the year this is
actually perfect timing I don't know
when this is going to air but like
November December when you look into
2024 or the next year I try to have one
big year defining thing on my calendar
every year last year was my bike ride
across America 2015 it was living with
the seal the book I wrote 2017 I lived
on a monastery 2016 or something I
started 29 or 29 this company with my
partner so there's an old Japanese
ritual called them a sogi and we took
the liberty to kind of create our own
version of what that means but basically
it means that every year you do one or
the way I've interpreted it is you do
one big year defining thing and you had
you should have something to show for it
every year by the way if you're 35 years
old I don't I don't just rounding up
here
um and you live to be 85
so you have that would be 50 year
defining things between now and the end
of year and the end of your run that you
have on your life resume that's pretty
damn incredible the second thing I do is
something I call Kevin's rule named
after my friend Kevin
um
which is every other weekend I do
something I normally wouldn't have done
it's like instead of watching like a
George the Georgia football game I might
take my kids fishing I might go to a
conference I might you know
um watch spend a couple hours learning
something I didn't know
um I coined at Kevin's rule because
Kevin and I were camping in Mount
Washington with our kids and it was like
I go cab there's eight it's like the
winter it's snowing we're sleeping
outside in a minus sporty sleeping bag
minus 20 sleeping bag I'm like cat
there's eight billion people in the
world man it's only us on this mountain
you know it how often do you do this
because he invited me he's like oh every
other week he's a police officer I do so
every other month I do something I
normally went to done I'm like what do
you mean he's like so at the end of the
year I got six mini Adventures if you're
35 and you live to be 55 and you have
six mini Adventures
that's 300 mini adventures and 30
50 I'm sorry 50-year defining things
you're musogi and 300 mini Adventures
Sean I don't care how much money you
have or how little money you have at the
end of your run if I go to you and
you're 85 years old on your deathbed and
you're like Jesse man thank you I took
your advice listening to my podcast and
I now have 50 unbelievable Adventures
I've done the Grand Canyon I've taken my
family and I have 300
Many Adventures that I've done and by
the way it only took six days of the 365
days of the year seven days of the 365
days of the year it's a two percent is
that two percent six percent what is
that you have a rule here we don't do
public math so don't worry you're off
the hook okay there we go
[Laughter]
that's a great rut
that's a great run
have you ever hung out with Rob Dyrdek
you guys are really similar we had him
on
um and I I think I've said publicly he's
one of my favorite people uh and you
have the similar quality where you just
have a framework and you know what you
like and you stick to it and you're
really intentional and I appreciate it
on your terms which is what I think the
highest calling thing we respect on the
Pod is somebody who defines their own
terms and then lives on them even if you
don't even if somebody doesn't even
successful people don't do that like
even people who are wealthy they're like
I [__] hate my life because I'm tied
to this job that I actually don't like
doing and you're a great example you're
you're you're your definition tends to
be exciting and awesome because you're
doing all these Adventures but it
doesn't matter what your your definition
of of like your framework is you've done
a cool job of defining it and sticking
with it and I appreciate that well one
cool thing that's different is Rob's is
all about maximizing he's like
efficiency how much how do I use my time
how do I allocate it and how do I get
the most done in that time whereas I
feel like just sees almost like it's a
different relationship with time it's
like how do I have the maximum number of
of incredible experiences
um and amazing relationships and moments
whether that moment took five seconds or
you know five days or five weeks it
doesn't really matter it's like
maximizing kind of like squeezing the
juice out of out of the fruit you know
versus versus uh you know trying to
optimize every moment
in in a generation of hustle and grind
which is so obvious no [__] you gotta
work hard that message gets lost and you
don't want to give up your 20s and your
30s and your 40s and certainly not your
50s if you can avoid it just grinding
and chasing something that you can get
the same feeling
doing something else well we feel lucky
for having having you on uh very early
on on the podcast Sam introduced me to a
guy Mike Brown and he said one line on
the Pod that changed my life he goes uh
he goes yeah my theory of life is find
the people that you love and then do
life with them and I just thought oh if
there's a North star for me like that's
the new North Star you know maybe
something maybe something more wise will
come take its place but that's it
and uh that's the pie
[Music]